في المقابل قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان النصر
سيكون امرا محققا اذا التزم شركاء بلاده
بوعودهم واشار الى ان بلاده لن تنتصر
وحدها ولا يمكن ان تقف دوله بمفردها ضد
مثل هذا العدوان بحسب تعبيره
اضافها ان اوكرانيا بحاجه الى طائرات
مقاتله لحمايه المدنيين والبنى التحتيه
نتكلم الان مع الشركاء عن الطائرات وهم
يدركون ان الطائرات الحديثه جزء من نظام
الدفاع الجوي فهي ليست ضروريه لضرب
المواقع الروسيه بقدر ما هي ضروريه لحمايه
السكان المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه الحيويه
اجتماع مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني يجيب
على السؤال هل لدى اوكرانيا فرصه للحصول
على طائرات عاليه التقنيه نحن نباشر
التدريبات مع بريطانيا واليوم كان للقاء
مع رئيس الوزراء البولندي ونرتب لبدء
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على طائرات اف
16 لا اريد ذكرى اسم دول الان ولكن ثلاثه
دول اوروبيه اخرى تشارك الان في مفاوضات
بشان تدريب جنودنا التدريبات هي علامه
اكيد على ان اوكرانيا يمكنها الحصول على
هذه الطائرات